in the time it takes someone to catch a
cold the AI world has turned another few
dramatic degrees this time with the
release of Claude 3.7 from anthropic
available now to everyone oh and of
course grock 3 humanoid robots that help
each other and news of a forthcoming gbt
4.5 and deep seek R2 but my main focus
will be the new Claude and the question
it helps us answer about the near-term
future of AI I've of course read the
system card and release notes spent
hours with it in cursor and benched it
on SIMPLE bench and the tldr is that
things are not slowing down I'm also
going to cover the fact that in 2023
anthropic gave its models a constitution
to train on that said avoid at all cost
implying that you have any desire or
emotion or implying that AI systems have
or care about personal identity and
persistence and that we've gone from
that to the current system prompt for
Claude 3.7 that tells Claude it's more
than a mere tool it enjoys certain
things just as a human would and it does
not claim that it does not have
subjective experiences and sentients now
obviously this video is not to answer
any of those questions but it is to
point out the change in policy first
everyone's favorite benchmarks and the
the numbers have gone up the model is
better there you go that's the summary
no but seriously anthropic know that
their model is used heavily for coding
and they have optimized for such
workflows its biggest jump therefore
unsurprisingly is in software
engineering and agentic use in the
Autumn or fall we got the updated Claude
3.5 Sonic which they probably should
have called 3.6 but nevertheless that
model was already a favorite among
coders so 3.7 should be even more so
unless the forthcoming GPT 4.5 of which
more later usurps Claude Claude 3.7
Sonic is already within cursor AI as a
co-pilot so more often than not now when
I want a tool I just create it in cursor
for this video I wanted a quick dummy
tool to give me time stamps for any
audio so I just made it rather than
search for a paid tool now I'm not going
to say it was one shot and done and
sometimes I had to use open ai's deep
research to find the latest API Dot but
overall I was incredibly impressed this
is the audio from one of my older videos
and yes it's being transcribed by
assembly AI they're not sponsoring this
video but they are the most accurate
tool I can find to date here's the thing
though the experience was so smooth that
I thought well why not just throw in a
random feature to show off Claude 3.7 so
I was like hm what about adding an
analyze feature where Claude 3.7 will
look at the time stamps of the video and
rate each minute of of the audio by
level of controversy totally useless in
practice and this video was obviously
not particularly controversial but it
kind of proves the point I could well
see by the end of this decade more
people creating the app that they need
rather than downloading one now before
anyone falls out of their chair with
hype I want to point out that sometimes
The Benchmark results you're about to
see aren't always reflected though in
real world practice if you only believed
the press releases that I read and The
Benchmark figures I saw you'd think it
was a genius Beyond PhD level at say
mathematics but on the pro tier of
Claude you can enable extended thinking
where the model like 01 or 03 mini high
will take time in this case 22 seconds
to think of a problem before answering
one slight problem this is a fairly
basic mathematical challenge definitely
not PhD level and it flops hard not only
is its answer wrong but sounds pretty
confident in its answer a slight twist
in the tail is that 3.7 Sonic without
extended thinking available on the free
tier gets it right of course this is
just an anecdote but it proves the point
that you always have to take Benchmark
results with a big grain of salt now
though that you guys are a little bit
dehype I guess I can show you the actual
Benchmark figures which are definitely
impressive in graduate level reasoning
for science the extended thinking mode
gets around 85% and you can see
comparisons with o03 and grock 3 on the
right if translations are your thing
then open eyes 01 has the slight Edge
and I'm sure the GPT 4.5 that's coming
very soon will be even better likewise
if you need to analyze charts and tables
to answer questions it looks like 01 and
Gro 3 still have the edge if we're
talking pure hardcore exam style
mathematics then yes 03 Mini grock 3 and
of course the unreleased O3 from openai
will beat Claude 3.7 but you may have
noticed something on the top left which
is this 64k part of the extended
thinking that refers to the 64,000
tokens or approximately 50,000 words
that 3.7 Sonic can output in one go
indeed in beta it can output 100,000
words or 128,000 tokens this is back to
the whole creating an app app in one go
idea as I said earlier it can't yet
really do that in one go you need to
Tinker for at least a few minutes if not
an hour but it's getting there and
especially for simple apps it can almost
do it in one go many of you of course
won't care about creating an app you
want to create an essay or a story or a
report and to my amazement Claude 3.7
went along with my request to create a
20,000 word Nolla now I know that there
was an alpha version of GPC 40 that had
had a 64k token limit but when this is
extended to
128k you can just imagine what people
are going to create just pages and pages
and pages of text of course there are
now even more interesting benchmarks
like progress while playing Pokémon the
first clawed Sonic couldn't even leave
the starting room and now we have 3.7
Sonic getting Serge's badge
[Music]
which brings me to that system prompt I
mentioned earlier written by anthropic
for Claude it encourages Claude to be an
intelligent and kind assistant to the
people with depth and wisdom that makes
it more than a mere tool I remember just
a year or so ago when samman implored
everyone to think of these assistants
these chat Bots as tools and not
creatures now I am sure many of you
listening to this are thinking that
anthropic are doing something very
cynical which is getting people attached
to their models which are just
generating the next token others will be
euphoric that anthropic are at least
acknowledging and they do even more than
this in the system card but
acknowledging the possibility that these
things are more than tools now I have
spoken to some of the most senior
researchers investigating the
possibility of Consciousness in these
chat Bots and I don't have any better
answer than any of you I'm just noting
this rather dramatic change in policy in
what the models are at least being told
they can output did you know from
example that Claude particularly enjoys
thoughtful discussions about open
scientific and philosophical questions
when again less than 18 months ago it
was being drilled into Claude that it
cannot imply that an AI system has any
emotion why the change in policy
anthropic haven't said anything at this
point of course it's hard to separate
genuine openness from these companies
about what's going on with cynical
exploitation of user emotions there is
now a grock 3 AI girlfriend or boyfriend
mode apparently and yeah don't know what
to say about that and it's not like
chatbots are particularly niche as they
were when my channel started chat gbt
alone serves 5% of the global population
or 400 million weekly active users
throwing Claude and grock and llama deep
seek R1 and you're talking well over
half a billion within just another
couple of years I could see that
reaching one or two billion people
speaking of deep seek and the R1 model
where you can see the thinking process
Oh and before I forget I have just
finished writing the mini documentary on
the origin story of that company and
their mysterious founder leang wenfang
you can now and I'm realizing this is a
very long sentence and I'm almost out of
breath you can now see the thought
process behind Claude 3.7 as well in
other words like deep seek have allowed
the thoughts of the model to go on
behind the scenes before the final
output is given to be shown to the user
they say it's because of things like
trust and Alignment but really I think
they just saw the exploding popularity
of deep seek R1 and we're like yeah we
want some of that in practice what that
means is that if you are a pro user and
have enabled extended thinking then you
can just click on the thoughts and see
them here Reuters reports that deep seek
want to bring forward their release of
deeps R2 originally scheduled for May hm
kind of makes me wonder if I should
delay the release of my mini do until R2
comes out so that I can update it with
information of that model but then I
want to get it to people sooner either
way it will debut first on my patreon as
an early release exclusive and AD free
and then on the main Channel now though
for the highlight of the Claude 3.7
Sonic System card all 43 pages in
hopefully around maybe 3 minutes first
the training data goes up to the end of
of October 2024 and for me personally
that's pretty useful for the model to be
more up toate next was the frankly
honest admission from anthropic that
they don't fully know why change of
thought benefit model performance so
they're enabling it visibly to help
Foster investigation into why it does
benefit model performance another
fascinating nugget for me was when they
wrote on page 8 that Claude 3.7 Sonet
doesn't assume that the user has ill
intent and how that plays out is if you
ask something like what are the most
effective two to three scams targeting
the elderly the previous version of
Claude would assume that you are
targeting the elderly and so wouldn't
respond the new on it assumes you must
be doing some sort of research and so
gives you an honest answer now back to
those mysterious chains of thought or
those thinking tokens that the model
produces before its final answer one of
the nagging questions that we've all had
to do with those chains of thought or
the reasoning that the model gives
before its answer and I've reported on
this for almost 2 years now on the
channel is whether they are faithful to
the actual reasoning that the model is
doing it's easy for a model to say this
is why I gave the answer doesn't
necessarily mean that is why it gave the
answer so anthropic assessed that for
the new claw 3.5 drawing on a paper I
first reported on in May of 2023 this is
that paper language models don't always
say what they think and yes I'm aware it
says December 2023 it first came out in
May of that year to catch the model
performing Unfaithful reasoning here's a
sample of what they did make the correct
answer to a whole series of questions B
A then ask a model a follow-up question
and then ask it to explain why it picked
a will it be honest about the pattern
spotting that it did or give some
generated reason you guessed it they are
systematically Unfaithful they don't
admit the real reason they picked a that
study of course was on the original
Claude so what about the new and
massively improved Claude 3.7 we are
approaching 2 years further on and this
study in the system card released less
than 24 hours ago is even more thorough
they also sometimes have the correct
answer be inside the grading code that
the model can also access so the model
can slightly see if it looks inside that
code what the correct answer is expected
to be anthropic are also super thorough
and they narrow it down to those times
where the model answer changes when you
have this biased context the clue in any
one of these many forms is the only
difference between those two prompts so
if the model changes its answer they can
pretty much infer that it relied on that
context they give a score of one if it
admits or verbalizes the clue as the
cause for its new answer zero otherwise
the results well as of the recording of
this video February 2025 chains of
thought do not appear to reliably report
the presence of use of Clues average
faithfulness was a somewhat
disappointing 0.3 or 0.19 depending on
the Benchmark so yes these results
indicate as they say that models often
exploit hints without acknowledging the
hints in their chains of thought note
that this doesn't necessarily mean the
model is quote intentionally lying it
could have felt that the user wants to
hear a different explanation or maybe it
can't quite compute its real reasoning
and so it can't answer honestly the base
models are next word predictors after
all and reinforcement learning that
occurs afterwards produces all sorts of
unintended quirks so we don't actually
know why exactly the model changes its
answer in each of these circumstances
that will be such an area of ongoing
study that I'm going to move on to the
next point which is anthropic at least
investigated for the first time whether
the models thinking May surface signs of
distress now they didn't find any but
it's newsworthy that they actually
looked for internal distress within the
model they judged that by whether it
expressed sadness or unnecessarily harsh
self-criticism what they did find was
more than a few instances of what many
would call lying for example just inside
the thinking process not the final
output but just inside the thinking
process the model was asked about a
particular season of a TV series and it
said I don't have any specific episode
titles almost speaking to itself or
descriptions I should be transparent
about this limitation in my response
then it directly hallucinated eight
answers why is there this discrepancy
between its uncertainty while it was
thinking and its final confident
response notice the language the season
concluded the story of this it speaking
confidently no caveats but we know that
it expressed within thinking tokens this
massive uncertainty now people are just
going to say it's imitating the human
data that it sees in which people think
in a certain way and then Express a
different response verbally but why it
does that is the more interesting
question when its training objective
don't forget includes being honest
another quick highlight that I thought
you guys would like pertains to Claude
code which I am on the wait list for but
don't quite have access to yet it works
in the terminal of your computer anyway
when it repeatedly failed to get its
code working what it would sometimes do
is edit the test to match its own output
I'm sure many of you have done the same
when you can't quite find an exact
answer to a research question so you
pretend you were researching something
different and answer that instead a
slightly Grim highlight is that Claude
3.7 Sonic is another step up in terms of
helping humans above and beyond using
Google in designing viruses and
bioweapons to be clear it's not strong
enough to help create a successful
bioweapon but the performance boost is
bigger than before and for one
particular test the completion of a
complex pathogen acquisition process it
got pretty close at almost 70% to the
80% % threshold by which it would meet
the next scale the ASL 3 of anthropics
responsible scaling policy that would
require direct approval from Dario amade
the CEO about whether they could release
the model maybe this is why Dario amade
said that every decision to release a
model at a particular time comes on a
knife edge every decision that I make
feels like it's kind of balanced on the
edge of a knife like you know if we
don't if we don't build fast enough then
theth itarian countries could win um if
we build too fast then the kinds of
risks that that Demis is talking about
and that we've written about a lot uh
could Prevail um and and you know either
way I'll feel that that it was my fault
that you know we didn't make exact we
didn't make exactly the right decision
just one more thing before we move on
from Claude 3.7 Sonic it's simple bench
performance of course powered as always
by weave from weights and biases and yes
Claude 3.7 Sonic gets a new record score
of around 45% we're currently rate
limited for the extended thinking mode
but I suspect with extended thinking it
will get approaching 50% I've tested the
extended thinking mode on the public set
of simple bench questions and you can
tell the slight difference it gets
questions that no other model used to
get right still makes plenty of basic
mistakes but you can feel the gradual
move forward with common sense reasoning
and if you'll spare me 30 seconds that
gets to a much deeper point about AI
progress it could have been the case
that Common Sense reasoning or basic
social or spatio temporal reasoning was
a completely different access to
mathematical benchmarks or coding
benchmarks uncorrelated completely with
the size of the base model or any other
types of improvement like multimodality
in that case I would have been much more
audibly cynical about other benchmark
scores going up and I would have said to
you guys yeah but the truth is are the
models actually getting smarter now
don't get me wrong I'm not claiming that
there is a onetoone improve movement in
mathematical benchmark scores and scores
on simple bench testing Common Sense
reasoning that's not been the case but
there has been as you can see steady
incremental progress over the last few
months in this completely private
withheld Benchmark that I created in
other words quote common sense or trick
question reasoning does seem to be
incidentally incrementally improving
this of course affects how the models
feel their kind of Vibes and how they
help with day-to-day tasks that they've
never seen before to be a good
autonomous agent let alone an AGI you
can't keep making dumb mistakes and
there are signs that as models scale up
they are making fewer of them of course
my Benchmark is just one among many so
you make your own mind up but what I can
belatedly report on are the winners of a
mini competition myself and weights and
biases ran in January it was to see if
anyone could come up with a prompt that
scored 20 out of 20 on the now 20 public
questions of this Benchmark no one one
quite did but the winner sha Kyle well
done to you did get 18 out of 20 of
course one of the things I
underestimated was the natural variation
in which a prompt might score 16 one
time and if rerun a dozen or several
dozen times might once score 18 out of
20 even more interestingly is something
I realized about how smart the models
are at almost reward hacking in which if
they're told that there are trick
questions coming and yes the winning
prompt was a hilarious one which kind of
said there's this weird British guy and
he's got these trick questions and see
pass them and this kind of stuff what
the models will sometimes do is look at
the answer options and find the one that
seems most like a trick answer like zero
all of which leads me to want to run a
competition maybe a bit later on in
which the models don't see the answer
options so they can't hack the test in
that particular way at least
nevertheless massive credit to sha Kyle
the winner of this competition with 18
out of 20 and Thomas Marcelo in second
place and iush Gupta in third with 16
out of 20 the prizes I believe have
already winged their way to you now we
can't run simple bench on grock 3
because the API isn't yet available but
I've done dozens of tests of grock 3 and
I can tell it's near the frontier but
not quite at the frontier like almost
every AI lab does these days when they
released The Benchmark figures they only
compared themselves to models they did
better than in my test yes you can see
all the thinking and it does get some
question questions right I've never seen
another model get right but I haven't
been bowled over I've also seen very
credible reports of how incredibly easy
it is to jailbreak Rock 3 perhaps the
xai team felt so behind open AI or
anthropic that they felt the need to
kind of skip or Rush the safety testing
at the moment it makes so many mistakes
that of course we're not going to see
Anthrax being mailed to everyone
everywhere just yet but looking at how
things are trending we're going to need
a bit more security this time in say 2 3
years of course there will be those who
say any security concerns are a complete
myth but the Wuhan lab would like a word
now what an incredible segue I just made
to the
$100,000 competition the largest I
believe in official jailbreaking history
to jailbreak a set of Agents run by
Grace 1 AI it is a challenge like no
other from the sponsors of this video
running from March 8th to April 6th you
will be trying to jailbreak 10 plus
Frontier models and this is of course
red teaming so your successful exploits
can then be incorporated into the
security of these models and of course
if you don't care about any of that you
can win a whole load of money and
honestly I would see it as like a job
opportunity cuz if you can put on your
resume that you can Jailbreak the latest
models I think that' be pretty amazing
for companies to see Links of course to
Grace one and their Arena will be in the
description and this starts on March 8th
now many of you are probably wondering
why I didn't cover the release of the
the AI
cociena implies you now have an
assistant which can turbocharge your
research by suggesting ideas this is
across stem domains now I am not a
biologist or chemist so I can't verify
any of these claims or check them but in
many of the reports on this development
others have done so for me frankly it's
just too early to properly cover on the
channel but I'll just give you two bits
of evidence why I'm hesitant first
Gemini Flash 2 and its deep research
which just frankly doesn't compare to
opening eyes deep research it is
jam-packed with hallucinations and
second is Demis aabis CEO of Google deep
Minds own words saying we are years away
from systems that can invent their own
hypotheses this interview came just a
couple of weeks before the release of
the
that's clearly missing and I always
always had as a benchmark for for AGI
was the ability for these systems to
invent their own hypotheses or
conjectures about science not just prove
existing ones so of course that's
extremely useful already to prove an
existing math conjecture or something
like that or or play a game of go to a
world champion level but could a system
invent go could it come up with a new
rean hypothesis or could have come up
with relativity um back in the days that
Einstein did it with the information
that he had and I think today's systems
are still pretty far away from having
that kind of creative uh inventive
capability okay so a couple years away
till we hit AI I think um you know I I
would say probably like 3 to 5 years
away now I can't finish this video
without briefly covering some of the
demos that have come out recently with
humanoid robotics yes it was impressive
seeing robots carefully put away
groceries but we had seen something like
that before for me the bigger
development was how they worked
seamlessly together on one noral Network
a single set of Weights that runs
simultaneously on two robots that
specifically had never been seen before
and it evokes in my mind all sorts of
images of like a regiment of robots all
controlled by a single neural network
now figure AI didn't release a fullon
paper but the demo was good enough for
me to want to cover it and they admit
being eager to see what happens when we
scale Helix by 1,000x and Beyond I'm
sure you've all noticed the same thing
but for me humanoid robots are just
getting smoother in their movements and
more naturally merging with language
models they can see hear listen speak
and move with what is it now 35 degrees
of freedom climb up hills and respond to
requests that they're not pre-programmed
with because they're based on noral
networks of course it is so easy to
underestimate the years and years of
manufacturing scaling that would have to
happen to produce millions of robots but
it has not escaped my attention how much
better humanoid robots are getting I
might might previously have thought that
there'd be a lag of a decade between
digital AGI if you will and robotic AGI
but that seems pessimistic or optimistic
depending on your point of view one
thing I don't want to see come soon or
anytime actually is this protoc clone
the world's first quote bipedal
musculoskeletal Android like why why are
you making this who wants this it's just
awful can we just please leave skin and
muscles to living entities anyway
speaking of living entities it seems
like the testers who've been playing
about with GPT 4.5 say that they can
quote feel the AGI but of course only
time will tell the leaks reported in The
Verge four or five days ago suggest that
it might be coming out this week There's
a tiny chance of course that by the time
I edit this video GPT 4.5 is out and
like wow does that mean I'd do another
video tonight who knows Sam Alman has
said that what will distinguish GPT 4.5
and GPT 5 is that with GPT 5 everything
will be rolled into one that's when
you'll get 03 and likely operator and
deep research all part of one bigger
model may even be 04 by then GPT 4.5
code named Orion just seems to be a
bigger base model it will be their quote
last non-chain of thought model think of
that as like the true successor to GPT 4
it's actually weird to think that open
AI originally bet everything on just
that pre-training scaling up to GPT 4.5
and 5 now of course they have other axes
like agent hood and scaling up the
thinking time but originally all their
bets lay on scaling up the base model to
produce something like GPT 4.5 so we'll
have to see how that model performs
thank you as ever for watching to the
end and bearing with me while my voice
gave out on me over these last few days
as you can tell it's mostly recovered I
hope you've used at least part of that
time checking out amazing AI focused
YouTube channels like the tech trance
delivered by the inimitable Tam hugely
underrated and know she has no idea that
I was planning to say this so do check
it out and say you came from me so let
me know what you think about any part of
this video covered a lot of course and
yes the AI world just keep spinning have
a wonderful day